let's stick in Michigan for a little bit
and go to Trent from Ann Arbor uh Trent
from Ann Arbor welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hi David can you hear me all right yes I
can
hey uh first want to say I've been
hoping to get in uh and talk to you for
a while now I've been watching for
almost a year uh love what you do really
great um definitely would love to see
more voices out there do what you do
thank you
um I wanted to talk about
I know you've been covering like the uh
other Republicans jumping in on the
primary and stuff
um and you've been talking about a lot
about like what they're doing makes no
sense right I fully agree it's like you
can't get
enough voters with Trump in the running
and I generally believe that most of
them are banking on Trump
dropping out for one reason or another
so I just wanted your thoughts on that
because that's the only way like the
only thing I can understand
they wanted you know yeah doing the way
they're doing it the way they're doing I
don't think your wrong Trent in the
sense that one idea about what's so so
there's a couple different ways that you
could try to win a Republican primary
you could try to win a Republican
primary by activating all the people
that already don't like Trump or you
could win a Republican primary by trying
to convince people who like Trump to
vote for you instead of trump or some
combination of these okay so these are a
couple different strategies if you're
trying to get the people who don't like
Trump to vote for you then you're gonna
have to criticize Trump and so far the
only guy who's really criticizing Trump
is Chris Christie DeSantis a little bit
but it's really Chris Christie who has
said I get it this nomination goes
through Trump so that's one approach the
other approach is okay if I sort of just
draw some distinctions with how I think
things should be done but don't really
insult Trump if Trump gets arrested
multiple more times and then it just
takes him off the campaign Trail and
whatever I can be here sort of like
Jerry in the episode where he's hanging
around the woman who just had a breakup
right he's like I'll just I'll be there
for her and then I'll just be there you
know the problem is DeSantis has 20
something so if DeSantis is already
doing that how is Tim Scott at two
percent gonna do the exact same thing
the math they can't all do it you know
so I don't I don't know what the
Dynamics of that primary will look like
in four to six weeks particularly now
with Christian who my guess is will get
at least attention for going after Trump
it'll be interesting to see what it
looks like in a month or two
well and I guess I guess uh my last plan
is and to extend it further I just don't
understand
how people can be so dense like
you know I look and I see what they're
all saying and just general Republican
talking points and you know how how
dangerously we've treated uh you know
we've been on the edge of losing our
democracy yeah and I'm just sitting here
like how are you all complacent with
this you know like why why are we why is
there not more outrage and more vocal
outrage why can't at a certain point we
just say stop you you can't do this you
can't lie and bring down our democracy
to suit your own needs I don't totally
get it I don't totally get it and it's
it's part of the I mean complacency or
even support for that I mean there's
still people who say Trump won there's
still people who defend the rioters from
January 6. it that's a much bigger
conversation Trent but bottom line it's
a mess it's a mess
I fully agree yeah
all right well sorry to end on such a
disappointing note but I do appreciate
it thank you David all right there is
traps from Ann Arbor listen let's get
out of Michigan now because we've we've
been going to so many no offense to
Michigan but we've got to go to some
other state I feel like